Ciao Maryners e benvenuti in un nuovissimo
video
Era da tantissimo tempo che volevo farlo finalmente lo sto per fare quindi ecco a voi il mio primo video ask!
È veramente allucinante che in tre anni di canale non. Ho mai fatto un video ask
Vergogna allora in questi giorni vi
Ho chiesto di inviarvi dei messaggi
Su director delle mail con le vostre domande perché appunto volevo
Coinvolgervi ulteriormente in questo video ask e quindi mi avete inviato un sacco di domande che io purtroppo dovuto selezionare
Quindi se non trovate la vostra domanda mi dispiace ma eravate veramente tantissimi video selezionato
Diciamo quelle un po più particolari che mi faceva piacere condividere con voi più avanti magari quelle che ho avanzato
Diciamo le utilizzerò per magari un secondo video ask anche un subito con la prima domanda lei la più gettonata ve
La fate spessissimo e quindi e arrivato il momento di dare una risposta a questa
Fatidica domanda cosa ti ha spinto ad aprire un canale youtube allora diciamo che il canale youtube
L'ho aperto un po dopo il mio percorso all'interno del mondo
del web è iniziato con facebook infatti coperto questa pagina facebook essenzialmente per cantare pubblicare cover poi però ho visto insomma che
tante tante ragazze e tanti ragazzi pubblicavano video
Divertenti e visto che mi hanno sempre detto. I miei amici e ora persone mi conoscono. Bene che sono una buffone vi piace far ridere
eccetera eccetera ho detto ma
proviamo a fare questa cosa
Ma non avevo assolutamente idea di quello che sarebbe successo dopo la prossima domanda è quando hai caricato il tuo primo video cosa hai provato
cosa ti aspettavi
allora quando caricato il mio primo video avevo una paura
allucinante
perché comunque era la prima volta che
Mi esponevo al giudizio di così tante persone quindi sicuramente ero presa malissimo
E non mi aspettavo dunque. La c'è l'unica cosa che speravo era di non. Essere massacrata di commenti negativi
quindi
ero lì ogni volta che arriva un commento
tutta e ansia perché avevo paura
Poi col tempo chiaramente ci
Ha fatto l'abitudine diciamo qual è stato il tuo primo video allora il mio primo video c'è anche se andato proprio sulla mia pagina facebook
E scorrete in basso troverete il primo video che 23 cantanti in tre minuti
allora fin da quando sono piccolo faccio imitazioni di cantanti o di personaggio eccetera eccetera quindi ho pensato di far appunto un video
Dove nyt a voi. I cantanti che mi piacciono. Di più che stimo. Di più e che mi venivano anche meglio e questo video
Ha avuto un successo allucinante dopo quel video dopo il successo di quel video ne ho pubblicato un secondo
Infatti quando mi chiedono qual è stato il tuo primo video mi confondo sempre tra questi due perché sono stati pubblicati
Vicino quindi è una tripla di stanza e hanno avuto un successo allucinante e sono completamente diversi perché un'ora 23 cantanti in tre minuti
L'altro era una parodia diciamo
Delle ragazze che fanno tutte le salutiste e pubblica alle foto su instagram dell'innse a latina e poi si mangiano la
carbonara e lascia all'insalata al cane quindi quello è stato mio primo video diciamo comico e
Niente, ho iniziato così fino a qualche anno fa ti saresti aspettato tutto questo successo
Allora come vi. Ho già anticipato prima no cioè proprio non avevo idea
di quello che sarebbe successo dopo
all'inizio ero appunto felicissima per questo
botto diciamo che ho fatto però non mi aspettavo sicuramente e che sarebbe poi andato tutto così
In crescendo diciamo cioè facile magari fare un video con milioni di più è difficile
mantenere una costante di video che piacciono al pubblico e appunto
Far crescere questa famiglia diciamo di follower di persone che ti seguono quindi, non
Mi aspettavo assolutamente che succedesse tutto questo quando avevi quindici anni qual era la cosa che appassionava di più allora sicuramente
ero tra appassionata di musica e
colleziona voci di collezionavo cassette e soprattutto adoravo cantare e
Cantavo sempre sempre a scuola nei miei compagni mi odiavano perché no in gita in mettiamo ai posti in fondo iniziamo
Il concerto dopo tipo 1 ora 2 ore di pullman
volevano buttarmi fuori prima dei 15 anni
La mia passione era la danza invece ho fatto dieci anni danza classica poi
Ho lasciato penso proprio intorno ai 14 anni spesso mi hanno chiesto ma perché hai lasciato danza
per chi fa danza è un trauma da abbandonare insomma
Diciamo che ho fatto questa scelta perché ho capito che non era la mia. La mia strada è
Una parte bellissima della mia vita è sicuramente è stata una mia passione lo è tuttora perché piace un sacco andare a vedere I balletti
Però diciamo che il canto e la recitazione
Sono un po più in alto per me che scuola superiore frequentato allora
Dopo le medie
Ho seguito la mia migliore amica che si è scritto lo scientifico quindi stupidamente non fate questo errore mi sono iscritto allo scientifico per stare
Insieme la mia migliore amica perché avevo strappa ura del mondo. Del liceo non fate questa regata perché dopo un anno e mezzo
E dopo tanti 3 e 4 il latino e matematica e qualsiasi materia scientifica
Ho deciso di cambiare perché se non mi avrebbero bocciato quindi
Sono passata al liceo linguistico che sicuramente faceva più per me
vogliamo spagnolo che va bene era vantaggiato perché mio papà spagnolo quindi era un passo avanti
francese e inglese e
infatti mi sono diplomata con
Il massimo dei voti come una vera secchiona quindi un consiglio per tutti voi mi raccomando scegliete la scuola adatta a voi
Non vi fate condizionare dagli amici perché poi prima o poi insomma I nodi vengono al pettine ecco
Qual era la sua materia preferita
Allora io ho sempre amato le materie umanistiche
tranne storia non mi è mai piaciuto particolarmente storia e
amavo filosofia amavo letteratura ma italiano letteratura inglese francese e
Spagnola erano proprio top per me è anche storia dell'arte mi piaceva un sacco
Allora questa domanda è molto bella infatti una di quelle che mi. Ha colpito di più
Cos'è per te la musica allora per rispondere a questa domanda vi vorrei raccontare un piccolo aneddoto non, so perché però quando ero piccolina
tipo elementari
Tra con tra. I compagni ci si facevano queste domande che ai tempi che sono fossero cretine però effettivamente è invece erano abbastanza
Profonde una di queste domande era ma se tu dovessi scegliere preferirei un mondo senza colori o senza musica
Allora vi. Ricordo che le mie compagne era sempre lì che stavano ore a pensare e se erano indecisi
Io invece espone roma mamma ma ragazzo ma stiamo scherzando ma senza colori tutta la vita io no ma non posso rinunciare alla musica
Quindi questo per farvi capire quanto la musica sempre stata importante per me mi
Ha accompagnato durante tutta la vita
Dei momenti belli nei momenti brutti c'è sempre stata e sempre stato mio fianco e per me come se fosse una migliore amica diciamo astratta
Vorresti un animale ne hai mai avuto uno allora sì da piccolo avevo un gatto miti che purtroppo non c'è più
Però. Il mio sogno è avere un cane mia mamma mi. Ha preso il gatto perché pensava
Giustamente che fosse meno impegnativo e visto che ero piccola anche se dice
Oh mamma, lo porto io foro proprio fuori sapeva già che comunque non ero in grado di
Averne pura e occuparmene come bisognerebbe e quindi
Mi è rimasto il pallino fin dall'infanzia di prendere un cane e prima o poi
prenderò un cane sto cercando di convincere salvo che non è molto dell'idea
Com'è nata. La tua passione per la comicità allora questa anche una bellissima domanda me la fate spesso è la risposta, è non
Lo so cioè, io penso di essere nata così con insomma questa vena comica e e questa voglia di fare
La buffone di far ridere gli altri
Di base da piccola già da piccolo facevo. Le imitazioni non. Dei cantanti, non
Dei personaggi famosi dei compagni di classe e degli insegnanti infatti il video che ho fatto degli insegnanti
Le tipologie di professori che ha avuto sempre successo in realtà è basato
Su fatti realmente accaduti perché la maggior parte di quelle tipologie erano rappresentavano dei miei professori reali di che segno, zodiacale
6 allora io sono nata il 16 luglio quindi sono, del cancro ma ho scoperto da poco
Ero convinta di essere ascendente cancro è invece no sono ascendente leone
Infatti leggendo appunto le caratteristiche dei vari segni io sono fissato mi piacciono queste cose dell'astrologia
e ho scoperto che
Sono, esattamente il connubio tra le caratteristiche. Del cancro e del del leone quindi per esempio le caratteristiche
Del cancro in cui mi ritrovo sono il fatto di essere molto legata al passato e alla famiglia
Questo è vero è invece del leone il fatto di essere molto insomma la tenace e combattiva
Per quanto riguarda il raggiungimento dei propri obiettivi che lavoro ore di fare da piccola alle elementari alle medie e al liceo
allora alle elementari
volevo fare la parrucchiera infatti uno dei primi giorni di scuola avevano chiesto di rappresentare
Disegnare insomma il lavoro che avremmo voluto a fare da grande tre grandi e io ho disegnato il mio bellissimo salone di bellezza
Del quale era la proprietaria chiaramente e
Io mi sono rappresentata bionda platino quindi che l'ho già molto come sono briand elementari e
Invece alle medie liceo già iniziamo a capire che mi sarebbe piaciuto fare musica mi sarebbe piaciuto recitare
Insomma intraprenderla la strada. Del del mondo dello spettacolo quindi
Dal parrucchiere poi ci sono solo più andata e non
Ho più sognato insomma di aprirmi mio salone che non mi avresti voluto avere ti piace il tuo nome allora
il nome marina mi piace però non me lo sento proprio tanto cucito addosso avrei preferito un nome un po più strong proprio deciso e
in particolare quando sono nata e c'è stata una divisione in famiglia perché mia sarebbero a chiamarmi
Francesca mia mamma mai a quella y e mio padre carmen perché il 16 luglio il giorno della mia nascita in spagna è
Il giorno della attività della virgen, del carmen quindi quando sono nata mia madre mi aveva messo il braccialettino già costretto
Il nome mai a bola y mio padre quando arrivate in ospedale tono assolutamente non vi
Piace maya e quindi doveva trovare una via di mezzo tra carmen che a quanto pare a mia mamma non. Piaceva più che altro perché
Essendo meta italiana metà spagnola quello era un nome molto da di spagna mar italia un po meno quindi non era molto convinta
L'ho trovato via di mezzo che era marina però
Se dovessi scegliere carme sinceramente non mi, non
Mi dispiacerebbe e anche il mio secondo nome che è aurora che anche quello molto romantico molto poetico però mi piace magari chiamerò misure così
Marina è il tuo vero nome
Allora il mio vero nome marina senza y e quando dovevo scegliere insomma un nome un nome d'arte un nome da
utilizzare insomma per il mio per il mio canale
Ho pensato marina con la y per renderlo diciamo un po diverso anche se in minima parte dal mio nome originale perché
stravolgere completamente
inventarmi un altro nome non mio mi faceva impazzire come the alla fine mi chiamo marina e
volevo però distinguere un minimo la marina persona la marina personaggio anche se in realtà
ovviamente siamo la stessa cosa però era giusto così in ospizio
Hai, mai pensato di lasciare youtube il mondo dei social perché non eri dell'umore giusto o semplicemente perché volevi staccare un po
Allora come tutte. Le persone in questi anni ho avuto delle giornate. No dei momenti in cui non. Avevo tutta questa voglia di
Fare video di essere felice contento cioè non è che non volevo che proprio non ero in quell umore in quel modo lì
cosa è successo che all'inizio in quei giorni smettevo di
fare video quindi facevo un po pausa poi ho capito che col tempo se
Facevo star bene gli altri quindi se facevo ridere gli altri automaticamente stavo bene anche io quindi
In quei momenti in cui ero un po triste facendo video e leggendo I vostri commenti ricevendo tutto il vostro affetto o soltanto
vedendo che voi lì magari avanti una brutta giornata
automaticamente guardato, il video stavate meglio mi faceva stare automaticamente bene quindi
È stata una roba come terapeutica e sono riuscita a superare
diciamo questa paura di fare video quando sono un po giù
Perché so che quello che mi date voi di ritorno è
praticamente la cura la medicina
Il viaggio che sogni da tanto allora uno dei miei sogni è sicuramente andare a new york non ci sono mai stata
Ho viaggiato abbastanza nella mia vita però diciamo che l'america non. L'ho mai visitata quindi sicuramente new york e la, california è
Anche un sacco vi piacerebbe visitare la a latina
cuba in particolare l'avana è uno dei miei sogni e insomma ho un po di viaggi
che vorrei pianificare prossimamente
cosa provi quando ti fermano per strada e ti chiedono una foto o quando si scrivono messaggi carini
Su direct allora quello che che provo è
Difficile da spiegare a parole perché come dico sempre cioè e proprio come se fosse una famiglia quindi
quando ricevo dei messaggi super carini a volte mi sento quasi
Che non me li merito. Non. So come dire perché non. Faccio niente di
Vinto il premio nobel per la pace cioè faccio dei video simpatici carini però non
So come dire non mi spiego tutto questo questo vostro attaccamento nei confronti che è una roba bellissima pro volte appunto paura di come
Non credo di meritarmelo vi faccio queste queste paranoie qua e quando vi fermate per stata
è bellissimo perché insomma è lì che ready proprio
Veramente il
così dice l'affetto dei fan perché il messaggio bellissimo
Mi fa un sacco piacere però quando vedi una persona che ti correggo un incontro che abbraccia. I quali si mette a piangere
liberamente che veramente capisci che insomma sta succedendo qualcosa di bello
siamo arrivati all'ultima domanda
L'ho lasciata per ultima perché forse anzi sicuramente è la più importante di tutte
cosa pensi delle persone che ti seguono e cosa siamo per te
Allora sembra scontato sembra banale ma siete a tutti gli effetti ormai la mia famiglia
Siete la cosa più bella che mi sia successa per adesso quindi sicuramente
devo tutto questo voi perché siete voi il motore insomma
Del personaggio marino comunque di tutto questo percorso che stiamo facendo insieme e spesso mi dicono perché fai così tante storie
La risposta è perché mi piace coinvolgervi durante tutta la giornata. Della mia quotidianità e
Per chi appunto di reputo proprio come degli amici e come nei. Gruppi workshop in cui si mandano foto ci si iscrive tutto il giorno
Ormai per me siete questo siete degli amici siete parte
Della famiglia e mi sveglio al mattino felice se leggo tutti I vostri messaggi se so che
aspettato mio video è
una roba che ormai è naturale però
riflettendoci bene una cosa super speciale che non capita tutti e
Quindi sono super orgogliosa di tutto questo e vi ringrazio tantissimo perché senza di voi tutto questo non, sarebbe mai successo
Eccoci arrivati alla fine del video spero che questo mio primo video ask vi
Sia piaciuto spero di aver risposto insomma alle vostre domande alle vostre curiosità e
Fatemi sapere qual è la domanda la risposta anzi che mi. Ha colpito di più
Commentando qui sotto se non avete ancora fatto iscrivetevi al canale e attivate la campanella vicino al tasso di iscrizione per non perdere
nessunissimo dei miei video
Prossimi chiaramente e ricordatevi anche di seguirmi, su tutti gli altri social facebook intera e music hall vi mando un bacione
gambadoro alla prossima